she said why did you wait three hours to
say you know no violence and you he
pulls out the tweets and he's like half
an hour after they breached I said no
violence no violations and then are you
gonna pardon people and he said I'll
take a look at it some people obviously
did bad things and they shouldn't be
pardoned he's completely right yeah No
One Believes you should be able to go
punch a cop randomly but like if you're
getting a tour through the capitol but
you know it's a little different right
the police opened the door for you and
let you in why are you being criminally
charged um you know the video the sound
bites that you hear from that I mean I I
think it demands much further
investigation and honestly the bigger
thing is
frankly almost regardless of even if you
did punch a cut I think you're still
entitled to Due Process yeah and that's
the problem that seems to be totally
missing meaning you know due process
doesn't mean we put you in jail for two
years or maybe we'll deal with it
someday and you know even with all of
this stuff going on even with all the
conspiracy theories that have come true
even with everything that we now know
they want to cast a wider net around
January 6 I'm like really like that's
what you're gonna look into not not
people who have real power and influence
in Government